Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Okay, today's Maestro Hook:...
...The Maestro Hook is a simple conversation hook...
...that you can use with people to get a good conversation going.
And today is about barhopping.
Japanese people like to go barhopping...
...and they drink in a lot of different places like...
But in the West, most people like to drink in one place.
They stay in one place and they don't go to different bars so much.
But in Japan, we call that barhopping, so please remember this word.
Okay, today's Maestro Menu:...
I'll have what she's having.
So, please practice.
What's on tap?
Okay, Maestro Lines.
"What are you gonna have?"
"Oh, I'll have a bottle of beer."
"Okay, I'll have what she's having."
"What's on tap?"
"Oh, we have Miller, Coors, Bud and Bud Light."
"Okay, I'll take a Bud."
"Okay, thanks."
Okay, that's it for today.
And there'll be more conversation pieces that you can practice next week, so...
...tune in to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
Alright, see you later!